[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
just a reminder just a reminder
Jack Smith and the doj is not going to
save our democracy it is not his job it
is our job to save democracy it is our
job
our job
I know everyone's excited about this
third indictment hell I'm excited I want
to have a party and today we're going to
have a party because I have Dr Rachel
bittickoffer on the show later on so
you're going to want to stay tuned for
the entire two hours today that's right
at the bottom of next hour Dr Rachel
bidikoffer will join us to run Victory
laps and tell you exactly why and how we
should politicize
the indictment of Donald Trump
to defraud the United States of America
and its citizens and steal away their
vote
again I I I've been listening to the
news this morning
I knew exactly what they were going to
say I know exactly the hopes that
they're trying to get up and listen I
know a lot of people are going to be
pissed off when I say this
you're just gonna be pissed at me
and I you know I I really I couldn't
give two shits less if you're mad at me
when I tell the truth
that's that's what I'm here to do is
give it to you straight not not
dress it up a bit on how it makes you
feel good
I'm not here to tell you exactly what
you want to hear because it's what you
want to hear that it's not why I'm here
and I do this show every single day that
is not what this is about
it's about delivering you commentary
that advances a narrative
and make sure that we can rid ourselves
in our government of this [__]
fascism
Trump is not the only threat
trumpism truly is American fascism and
the real America First Nazis are the
threat
is he the cult leader of the Nazis yes
yes he is the leader he will be the
nominee
and to act like and to Hope and to pin
your your your entire
future of your democracy on one man who
is going to take down Donald Trump is a
big [__] mistake
Jack Smith knows exactly what he's doing
Jack Smith knows the task
Smith has Donald Trump by the short in
curlies but Jack Smith's job is not to
save democracy it is to prosecute crimes
remember this
it is your job you the citizen of the
United States of America the person who
has the power of the ballot to save our
democracy
so when you're listening to commentators
and legal analysts and I know people get
mad when I say this because they think
I'm painting broad strokes but the broad
Strokes that I'm painting are the people
who say this
that if we just if we just convict
Donald Trump before the election then it
will save us
it will not save us from fascism
that is one hundred percent incorrect
it will remain incorrect for a long long
time it is going to take a lot of work
we cannot back down we cannot give up we
cannot keep using our voices
just because Jack Smith indicted Donald
Trump doesn't mean it is over
this is only the beginning
the manga cult is is going to solidify
behind him
they want him to be indicted they want
him to go to trial that is what they
want
I know it's like with Tony they don't
want [__] they want him to be a
martyr the people who really truly
understand how fascism works and
understand that they want to advance
their cause in this country that fascism
has to live past Trump
he has to be their martyr if it lives on
past him
I mean Jesus Christ the guy's almost 80.
there's the likelihood that he'll choke
on a Big Mac before he even sees a trial
listen
to me when I say this
do not pin your hopes that Donald Trump
will receive the 14th Amendment and we
will all be saved
do not pin your hopes on that
pin your hopes on your effort pen your
hopes on your hope pen your hopes on
your engagement of your democracy it
will win we will beat them
they do not have the numbers they will
not have the numbers
but if you don't stay
vigilant if you do not stay focused on
the task at hand they can win
they can win
it is highly unlikely
but if your attention is paid only only
to the fact that Jack Smith is going to
save you and your democracy you may be
disappointed
so I urge you
I ask you
please
understand what is at stake
and there is much more at stake than
this just Donald Trump
and his stupid [__] legal arguments
that aren't going to hold water in court
when he gets there
they're already laying out a strategy to
delay this trial that is going to be the
number one goal because his only hope
out of this his only hope
out of this situation is for him to win
the election next year
that's it
Congress is not going to save him
fake ass Hunter Biden stories are not
gonna save him
stupid fraudulent
impeachment inquiries are not going to
save him
attorney generals and secretaries as
States and governors are not going to
save him
state legislators are not going to save
him
his little sycophants and his cults
are not going to save him
he knows this the only thing that will
save him is if he wins
he knows this they know this
you should know this
know the truth the truth will guide you
the truth will show you the way that you
need to engage in your democracy
and giving up and saying well I'm just
going to let Jack do his his thing to
save our democracy
is the wrong decision
so when Talking Heads tell you that oh
he's definitely gonna go to trial he's
definitely going to be convicted he's
definitely going to be 14th he's
definitely not going to be able to run
for president
they are feeding you full of a bunch of
misinformation
they may not be lying to you because
that may be the truth
well we're not even close to knowing if
that is the truth
so understand in this moment why it is
so important
to know
what your responsibility is in your
democracy
it is a republic only if we can keep it
us the people the government it is us we
decide
and together we can save our democracy
from fascism
I come here two hours a day and show you
every day and sometimes it's obscure
things
you're like well why does that have to
do with the the destruction of our
democracy I'm going to show you a couple
of Clips today that you're going to go
Jesus Christ this has nothing to do with
Trump's indictment why is this so
important
the advancement of fascism the
continuation of fascism
is the threat
Donald Trump is not the president of the
United States we can prevent him from
being the president of the United States
honestly it's one of the easiest races
will win
but we have to win it
we have to play
we have to strategize we have to engage
we have to do it together
if we don't actually do the action of
democracy and using the power of our
ballot he could win
he could win
Tony you're so dark today why are you so
dark
he's indicted we know the crimes he
committed
Jack Smith has written this indictment
to lock him up for a long time
and if you read the 45 pages of this
indictment you know
I was sitting there through every single
January 6 hearing and there was New
Evidence
that points to the fact that Donald
Trump knew he lost and he continued to
defraud the United States of America
this is not a an issue of free speech
this is the argument that they keep
making
is ridiculous your first amendment does
not protect you from defrauding the
United States of America
that's not what it protects you from
the other thing that is significant
about this indictment is Jack Smith did
not charge him for the insurrection
where he went to the ellipse and used
his speech to incite violence
Jack Smith has called a mulligan on that
one
so their their defense of free speech I
welcome
Jack Smith welcomes the prosecutors
but we must stay vigilant we must stay
in the game we cannot and should not
listen to people who tell us that we
should count on Jack Smith and the doj
to save our democracy
and I don't care who they are
it does not matter to me if they're
saying it they're feeding you full of a
bunch of misinformation and I stand on
that on that principle and if you don't
like it fine be mad at me but go tell
people you're mad about what I'm saying
go tell them
everyone you know tell the people that
you think I'm talking about
so they can challenge me
our democracy
is only if we can keep it
if we're willing to do the work to keep
it
and to feed people full misinformation
because you want them to feel good about
what this indictment means when we
haven't even seen the indictment be
arraigned on Donald Trump
is it dereliction in your duty as a
commentator and analyst and someone who
claims to know about election politics
our democracy and our country
full stop period I don't care what
network you're on I don't care what
credentials you have
folks here's the risk and listen to me
please I know this sounds dark but I'm
trying to give it to you straight
we're gonna we're gonna raw raw the
indictment today don't worry don't worry
we're gonna rah-rah the indictment we're
getting there
but in this moment
in this moment of History one of the
dumbest moments in history I'm gonna
show you and give you proof today that
our grandchildren learning that this
history will be the dumbest history that
they learn ever
it is ridiculous it is the worst
timeline that we possibly could be in we
are truly at the intersection
WrestleMania in real life
but here's the risk
if we convince people in this country
that Donald Trump definitely will go to
trial and Donald Trump will definitely
be convicted and jailed and he will
never be president because Jack Smith
and the Department of Justice will put
him in the jail no worries don't fret
just let them do their jobs and Donald
Trump will go away
and what happens if what happens if he
doesn't
hear me what happens if Donald Trump
does not go to trial next summer hmm
what happens
if they punt this past the election
and millions tens of millions of
Americans who were relying on the fact
that they were told by all the experts
that Donald Trump would definitely go to
trial is not at trial and is not going
to see Justice
they will falsely
suppress their own vote that is right
people will get discouraged
people will disengage
in our democracy that is the last thing
we need that is the last thing our
democracy needs
it is dangerous
to lead people down the road
of self-disenfranchisement
and that is the road that is why my
narrative is the way it is now I truly
believe that Donald Trump will not go to
trial I believe that in my heart of
hearts I think he's going to delay this
in into the delegate count and to him
collecting delegates and there's no way
they can send him to trial when he has
the delegates he has
and they're going to let the American
people decide whether he should be the
president of the United States or not
simple
it pisses you off you don't like to hear
it it isn't something that you want
but it's probably going to be the way
it's going to go
I'm telling you
it is important
that you know what can and cannot happen
and you should start from the worst case
scenario
and engage in your democracy at the
worst case scenario this this isn't this
isn't the Republican Party who wants to
lower taxes on rich people
they're trying to legislate our fellow
Americans out of existence they're
attacking children the lgbtq community
the bipod community
their history Ron DeSantis in Florida is
like yeah slavery was good
the risk is in front of you
do not
just because we can celebrate and go
yeah finally accountability for his
crimes
we cannot close our eyes because Justice
is around the corner
we must keep our eyes wide open
and we must work harder than ever to
make sure everyone in this country knows
the risk
if he continues to be their leader and
they get their grubby little [__]
hands on our government ever again
it is time
it is time now
to understand what the risk is fascism
is knocking at our door
we cannot wait
for Jack Smith we cannot wait for the
Department of Justice we cannot wait for
judges decisions on motions to save us
it is our actions it is our engagement
it is our strategic outrage
that will deliver democracy to us in the
future to our children our grandchildren
and Beyond
only this
only this is true
rather he goes to trial or he goes to
prison or he gets locked up
or somehow they prevent him from running
or somehow some other idiot gets the
nomination the Republican Party
we don't know
that are those are facts that have not
happened yet
do not base
your ideals do not base
your engagement in your democracy based
on facts that have not happened
base them on facts that exist now
right now in this moment
I'm going to show you a clip from Rush
Limbaugh
and I believe this clip from from
several years ago
Benji Johnson
she posted it
on Twitter
as if it was a flex
and I'm here to tell you that Rush
Limbaugh almost everything he says In
that clip is absolutely 100 percent
correct
he's speaking about the Maga cult
and he's absolutely correct in this clip
and when you hear it and you know what
he's saying and you know who he's
talking to and why he's saying it maybe
you'll understand maybe you'll finally
figure out that you should stop
listening to people that tell you that
the doj and Jack Smith are gonna rid us
of fascism because they're not
they're not
they may prosecute Trump they may
convict Trump they may put Trump behind
bars but that will not rid us
of fascism
We the People
have a referendum we the people are
Trump's jury we the people will show
fascisms in this country what we are
made of
if we don't
your lifestyle
the community you know
the people that you love
the history that we have made may all be
lost
and not just here but all around the
world
we are the become Beacon of freedom and
liberty in this country
We Are The Shining City
on the hill
the dreams of so many people all around
the world who have come to this country
for Generations
have made the American dream something
to be proud of
so don't rely on one man
don't rely on one man to save you
because if you do if you do
you're doing exactly as the Maga cult
would do
remember Donald Trump stood on stage in
and he said
out of his own mouth
as he received the nomination
only I can fix it
Jack Smith is not the only one that can
fix it folks
he is not the only one that can fix it
it is us as a collective
as a pro-democracy coalition
to save this country
to advance this nation into the future
to give Liberty equity and equality
to your children your grandchildren
and their children
and well beyond
and they will fight fascism too because
it will hide underneath its Rock and it
will come back with the Vengeance and
rear its ugly head and the reason why is
because ideas just won't die
they will always live in the dark
waiting
for the opportunity for us
to let down our guard
so do not let down your guard don't do
it I beg of you
this is just the beginning
this is just the start
there at the front door and they are
knocking and they are not backing down
they are going to follow him into the
pits of fascist hell if they must
and we must stand and defend our
democracy
it is imperative
did you think this was the rant that I
was going to give for his indictment you
thought I was going to run a bunch of
like oh we're going to run laps don't
worry we're going to run Labs here on
the Tony Michaels podcast today as we do
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube don't forget to subscribe
here on YouTube it's free
it's free to subscribe on YouTube you
crazy animals hit the like button or hit
the dislike button if you don't like
what I said this morning great fine if
you're like Tony you bastard oh you're
gonna be totally optimistic if you don't
think I'm optimistic about my democracy
I'm just trying
to tell you that people are feeding you
full of misinformation already
[__] hasn't been indicted for
more than 12 hours and they're already
feeding you full of disinformation
already giving you hope that doesn't
exist yet
it's that that's not gonna help
you your strategic outrage
your voice
your ballot
you engaging in your democracy that is
what will save it I'm telling you
just look at 2022 just look at 2020.
when we all banded together
remember there was supposed to be a red
wave oh my God they were gonna kill us
in these elections
Pennsylvania Arizona Michigan Wisconsin
we're gonna go red that was their plan
to steal the election in 2024.
that was their plan and we stopped them
we stop them
us the people
because I know one fact is true
this country does not get does not give
two [__] about Donald Trump
the majority of this country would have
wanted him to go away in 2016 when
Hillary Clinton won the popular vote
they do not want him
even the Republican Party are tied to
him like an anchor
and they are struggling to get rid of
him
so don't buy the big lie and the big lie
isn't that
Trump won
the big lie is that Trump has big
support
he doesn't
just like I told you Ron DeSantis would
flounder Donald Trump does not have the
support that they think they have he has
just enough support to to secure the
nomination in Republican primaries but
let me tell you something it is not
enough
it is not enough for him to be the
president of the United States if you do
something about it
if you do something about it
if you give up if you stop working
because you think someone else only Jack
Smith can fix it
only Jack Smith only the judge in D.C
can fix it only Merrick Garland can fix
it
it's a lie it's misinformation it's
[__] really to be frank with you
anyone saying it's full of [__]
and I don't care who says it if they're
saying it come at me show it to me I'll
challenge them I don't care who they are
or what their credentials are
if they say that [__] even close to that
[__]
they are feeding you full a bunch of
misinformation because they don't know
they don't know
they thought oh man this is gonna be a
rocket docket down in Florida I heard
that [__] I'll give you the evidence
right here oh it's gonna be a rocket
docket down in Florida
he's gonna go to trial we're going to
get him at trial oh man it's gonna be
great it's gonna be fantastic he's gonna
be in prison before you know it
all of a sudden the trial is kicked to
next year
right in the right in the heart of
primary season when he'll be collecting
up delegates more than enough reason for
judge Cannon
his judge his judge
to punt this trial
and she chose that date knowing that
all but Tony this judge this judge in DC
she was appointed by Barack Obama
don't count your chickens
do not place and pin the hopes of
democracy on what a judge's decision
will be in a [__] criminal case do
not it will be a mistake
a big big mistake and I'm telling you
the people in the media that are saying
this stuff are making big big mistakes
and they're making they're setting
dangerous narratives
very danger they it's dangerous
it's dangerous to our democracy to set
these narratives
and they give their caveats
well maybe sorta kinda maybe if maybe so
it's dangerous
we know the facts
we know we know we know what we know
and we can work forward from there
so if you hear me
and you understand what I'm saying
yell it scream it loud and clear when
you hear it point it out tell them
that's that's misinformation that's
that's just not what what we know
you may not be lying you may be telling
the truth in the future but today it's
misinformation
and today is the most important day
right now in this moment
as we sit here as we examine this
45-page indictment
as we try to figure out who
co-conspirator number six is oh God
that's a big question this morning all
the commentators are going to say it's
this person
ah it's got to be that [__]
It's gotta be Mike Flynn it's got to be
Genie Thomas it's got to be this person
because commentators let me tell you
they want to be right
oh man they want to be correct
oh boy if they were just right all the
time would it just be all warm and fuzzy
they're not trust me we're not we're
just [__] humans with ideas and the
ability to speak those ideas and
communicate them to mass amounts of
people that's it
we're not superheroes
sometimes I brag and it feels like I
have a crystal ball I do not
it doesn't exist
you can't tell the future
but today you know what the facts are
today and today what you should do is
you should make sure to subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast that's what you
should do right now hit the like button
if you hate what I say hit the dislike
button I don't give a goddamn and just
engage come in yelling scream at me at
the comments speaking of comments oh my
God so I I had a Discord for a while a
Discord server if you guys don't know
what a Discord server is don't fret
I had no idea either until just was it
yesterday or the day before I'm losing
track
but there's been like 200 people joined
the Discord server and you should have
seen last night the conversation that
went on as indictment watch happened it
was absolutely incredible it was almost
like the YouTube chat 2.0
all night long that's right that's right
to the chat family out there whether
you're on YouTube whether you're on
Facebook at the Tony Michaels chatting
right now or you're on Twitch at
twitch.tv slash the Tony Michaels if you
like the chat if you love the [__]
fam chat boy I tell you you're gonna
love this Discord
I'm not cheating you you're gonna love
it I was like whoa this is just like the
YouTube chat this is just like the
twitch chat everybody's in here yapping
and talking and yelling and screaming
and cheering last night giving each
other information I was dropping
information as it came as I found it
so that everyone had I know the mighty
librarian was posting the 45 page
indictment as soon as it dropped
she's a librarian she knows how to get
this information she knows how to get it
to your to you quickly so if you want to
continue the chat outside the show
it is the perfect way to do it I had no
idea honestly I had no idea about
Discord I didn't know the power of it
but it is really really engaging
and the audience is all going over there
so what you can do here's the way you
can do to go to the Discord you just go
to the Tony michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com scroll down you'll see
Discord server link under social media I
think it's podcast I don't remember
exactly where it's at but it says
Discord server just click Discord server
that'll take you straight there
now you can either do it on your
computer you can download the app
and I thought oh man it's going to be
difficult
to learn this thing it's really easy if
you know how to do the YouTube chat or
you know how to do the twitch chat or
you know how to chat in Facebook you're
going to know how to chat in this thing
and we set up different rooms in the
Discord we got we got the lobby where
everyone's talking right now there's the
Live Chat Show going on Joy leaves in
there Britney's in there rocks in there
uh let's see your highness is in there
the mighty librarian Andrea is in there
let's see who else is in there there's
so many people in right now in the live
show chat right over there right now as
we speak
on Discord
I know I I had no idea honestly I didn't
know
skip over there we made him a moderator
he's been streaming streaming shows and
streaming audio all almost all night
the entire time
so if you like the chat if you like
being part of the [__] fam I would
highly suggest you go over to that
Discord server
you're gonna find all your friends there
all your chat friends there your chat
buddies you're gonna find them there on
the Discord server and again if you
don't know what Discord is don't worry
and if you're scared about you know
maybe learning something new I'm
learning it too don't worry I don't know
[__] about it I have no [__] about it
I've been private messaging people who
do knew something about it to figure out
how to do it
so don't worry don't fret you will learn
you will be a Discord expert before you
know it so go to the Tony michaels.com
that's the Tony michaels.com and follow
the Discord server there I've got a
great guest for you today we're going
over time here I'm way past the bottom
of the hour but you know it's just me
today Gabe Sanchez not in some for some
reason my TV behind me you see that's
messing up I don't know
I'd consider going to a break so I can
figure that thing out while uh while I'm
on break which I'll probably do
I'm not gonna lie
but I'm not done talking yet
am I ever done talking oh boy oh boy
so go to the Tony michaels.com and find
the Discord server there also also don't
forget if you are on Twitch go to
twitch.tv slash the Tony Michaels
if you have your Amazon Prime account
make sure your reset subscribing we've
we're down in resubs right now there are
several people who have not resubscribed
with their Amazon Prime account here's
how it works if you have an Amazon Prime
account and you want to watch on Twitch
commercial free this is the best way to
do it and we get a couple bucks here at
the show every month that's right Amazon
gives us a couple dollars of Jeff
bezos's money like it's directly out of
his pocket when they send the check it
says Jeff's money I'm just kidding just
making that up
but they do send us a couple bucks but
it's not Jeff's money well kind of sorta
anyways
if you link your Amazon Prime account to
your Twitch account you get one free
subscription it's free to follow us on
Twitch it's kind of weird you follow us
on Twitch for free you subscribe for
money
but if you have an Amazon Prime account
it's free to subscribe you just link
your Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account and you give us that one free
subscription you get with Amazon gaming
all the directions are on the Tony
michaels.com so just go to the Tony
michaels.com again it's the fourth link
down link your Amazon Prime account to
your Twitch account and give us a couple
bucks and also the directions to
re-subscriber there too
so if you haven't re-subscribed and you
need to and you need to figure it out go
to the Tony michaels.com the directions
are right there on that link super easy
quick fast boom bingo bango bongo
we've had a few a few subscribe this
morning five months in a row
so go to the Tony michaels.com figure
that out also visit the patreon link
there we're going to be doing democracy
roundtables of democracy I think I'm
gonna do another one tomorrow
we're gonna find some I don't I'm trying
to get guests scheduled but I didn't
have them scheduled this week so we're
just going to do it on our own we're
just gonna go find a resource we're
gonna scour through that resource I'm
going to show you how to use that a lot
of people were talking about
um some sort of a resource where they
could see all the laws that have to do
with registering voters I think that's
what we'll go through tomorrow so if you
want to see the resource that you can
tap into to find all the information
that you need about registering voters
in your state in your state because it's
a big huge registry and we're going to
figure out how to regi how how to find
the information that you need how to get
there so that you can register voters or
know how to register voters join us
tomorrow on the round table of democracy
if you want to participate in the live
event go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels again if you want to
participate in the live event go to
patreon.com D Tony Michaels don't worry
though if you're not a member of patreon
do not worry
I'm going to provide it for the public
for free that's right after we're done
recording it and we done do the piece of
content in the video I'm gonna put it on
the round table democracy playlist which
is on YouTube that's why also you want
to subscribe here on YouTube you go to
the the playlist tab there's a round
table of democracy playlist
we will put that video for the public to
see on Friday morning early for you to
use it for you to go and find that
resource and how to use that resource to
look up those specifics on registering
voters in your state
I'm excited about this I'm excited about
today it's a hell of a week it's a hell
of a day it's the third indictment day
it's indictment week again
[Laughter]
oh three times Trump don't go anywhere
don't go anywhere don't touch that dial
as they say on radio we'll be right back
right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
all right let's get excited let's get
pumped up about the indictment
I think it's so great because they
indicted you gotta be here by tomorrow
[__]
I mean not tomorrow but you know
get your ass here on Thursday
[__] basically
um what's gonna happen and Donald and
Donald Trump is not going to stop to uh
go
uh have have it have a great grand CNN
MSNBC Fox News follow him around the
country with his plane and all that
[__] [__]
he's not going he's not gonna pass up
that opportunity for him to be the the
entire news all day long Thursday so
there's no way he's going to do some
sort of phone-in arraignment
he's definitely going to go in person to
be arraigned I mean Jesus it only takes
15-20 minutes he's only going to be
arraigned on four charges they're not
going he's not gonna make him read the
45-page indictment in open court
so he's just gonna go he's gonna be
processed in DC be arraigned by a
magistrate it's not even the the judge
that will oversee his trial
so
it's how this stuff works though that's
how this stuff works
uh Buster asked here on on Facebook he
said who's uh doing the bonehead of the
week with Tony this Friday that's a good
question buster
should I leave it as a surprise or
should I just tell you
I don't know I talked to the person
yesterday they confirmed yes they want
to they want to help me do bonehead of
the week the last the last guest
bonehead of the week that we had was
Rachel bidikoffer Dr Rachel bidakoffer
which we have on today
and uh at the bottom of the next hour
so again about 45 minutes before Rachel
joins us
but who do you think it is maybe we
should play like a guessing game
who do you think it is
who do you think it is who do you think
is going to be the bonehead of the week
I don't know what do you think
everyone wants me to tell him
um
everyone says yeah I want you to tell me
[Music]
let's see Texas Paul no it's not Texas
Paul maybe I'll do like a a narrowing
down see Buster Buster says surprises
muster you asked
you asked and then you want me to
surprise you is it Rachel no it's not
Rachel
it's not Dr Rachel bidikov or she's on
today
she's joining us today I I was texting
him yesterday
I was like
I was like oh it's great she's so
excited she's going to be really excited
she's gonna have a smile from ear to ear
today and you're gonna hear that great
laugh that Dr Rachel bittick off her
hands I'm sure
and I I know I know I know
I know
that she's gonna have a lot of great
commentary to give you on how to
politicize this uh major oh Jedi no it's
not major some people are saying Fred
it's not Fred Wellman some people are
saying just Piper it's not just Piper
I'm
are we narrowing it down
oh the greatest part is it's right on
the tip of my tongue just like who is
the number six co-conspirator so we know
some of the code conspirators
right we know some of them
we know some of them we know number one
is Reed Rudy Rudy kaluti Grandpa farty
mcsharty Rudy Giuliani
which is not surprising which here's
what here's what this tells me about
Rudy Giuliani more than likely because
we know Rudy went before the grand jury
to testify Rudy was trying his ass off
to save his own skin now he's on there's
an interview and we might show it today
in the clips and there's an interview
with Rudy Landslide absolutely losing
his mind and they're all talking about
the First Amendment get the [__] out of
here with that nonsense
Jack Smith is not charging him with his
speech Jack Smith is charging him with
his actions
okay
listen
I I've told you this time and time and
time again about freedom of speech and
what it is and that these boneheads
don't know what the [__] freedom of
speech is and this is a more more of a
prime example
and honestly I welcome I welcome this
uh uh This bone-headed legal argument
and really honestly this bone-headed
narrative because that's all it truly is
is a narrative right like this isn't a
real legal defense
that somehow you think just because you
continued to act on your lies that it's
your freedom of speech get the [__] out
of here
I've told you before that
there is a difference between freedom of
speech and non-freedom of speech which
could seem like freedom of speech for
boneheads
okay let's say you don't like Walmart
right for whatever reason there's a
plenty of reasons not to like a [__]
Walmart right number one they're [__]
huge the parking lots are stupid
but also they they're they suckle at the
teeth of the middle class in this
country but you know for Pure blooded
profit there's a lot of things to hate
about those [__] right
and you can go protest you can go
protest
a Walmart
now you can use your freedom of speech
but what you can't do what you can't and
you can hold a big ass sign that you
made on the public sidewalk just beyond
Walmart's property line right you can
hold the sign says [__] Walmart [__]
them
[__] them
what you can't do is get a can of spray
paint
and write [__] Walmart on the side of
their building
okay you can spray paint your sign and
hold your sign Beyond Walmart's property
but you do not get to spray paint
[__] Walmart on the side of their store
it's against the law
even though you're using your speech
it's not speech anymore you're acting
on your speech you [__] idiot
so when you're seeking ways to overthrow
the government because you're saying
well I won boo who I didn't lose I won
boo who you can continue to stand there
and say that stupid [__] you you lines
are protected by freedom and speech but
your actions are not protected with the
First Amendment only your speech
[__] bonehead yes this is a good
point Buster brings up
on Facebook you cannot call in a bomb
threat you cannot yell fire in a crowded
theater
you cannot create action with your
speech that is illegal
that's really bone-headed argument but
let them keep making it honestly this is
the best thing that we have no matter
when he goes to trial no matter when
this happens
he is going to lose with this legal
argument full stop 100 it is going to be
[__] beautiful to watch them Crash
and Burn to the Earth
[__] him do it that's like him the
presidential records act the
presidential records Act
it has nothing to do with the case down
in Florida not a goddamn thing just like
his first amendment has nothing to do
with the case in D.C
you [__] idiots
keep going
keep at it
I don't give a [__]
it's the best argument they have to make
let's see um some other people are
postulating uh who is the um
the guest host on Friday let's see we
had some people let's see did it it did
no it's not Jack Smith I'm you think
Jack Smith
oh
um oh Jetta no it's not a Jetta it's not
Michael Cohen uh it's not Trey Crowder
let's see who it's not been Glebe it's
not Jordy it's not Brett it's not been
my zealous it's not Hal Sparks it's not
Tennessee Brando
I've seen some people say who it is in
the chat I'll give you that clue some
people in the chat have have you know
Dash dubrowski no it's not Dash
some people have uh got it correct here
um if that helps with uh who it is
[Laughter]
oh boy
now I'm gonna tell you I promise I'm
just gonna hang you a little bit on the
no it's not Gabe it's not Gabe Gabe's
not gonna be here
JFK or JFK Jr it could be JFK I hear JFK
Jr still alive Beau of the fifth column
no it's not Bo
um no it's not Leb Barnes It's not Lee
McGowan politics girl everyone's
guessing I like this game I like this
guy I typically don't like guessing
games especially when someone's making
me guess but this is kind of fun
no it is not Jank Unger no absolutely
[__] not
he would be he's been on the bonehead of
the week did you know that he's been one
of the contestants on bone of the week I
don't remember if he if he won or not
but
I can't remember I can't remember but
it's a it's a great day today in our
democracy
it is a great day it's not Michael Cohen
it's not Texas Paul it's not Rachel
it's not Michael popock I've had Michael
popock on the show though
you know what I mean so let's play this
guessing game who do you think number
six is a lot of people are saying oh
it's Jeannie Thomas Michael Flynn Roger
Stone
it is it it appears to someone not is
not a lawyer so it wouldn't probably be
Jeannie Thomas
Jeannie Thomas I believe has her law
license I believe she's a lawyer
if I'm if I'm incorrect about that
someone can can tell me but I think
Jeannie Thomas is a lawyer
um some people are saying Navarro but
but it alludes to the fact in the
indictment that is possible it's
possible that it's not
an attorney
and the other thing too is it doesn't
really say like if it's a he or a she
you know doesn't give their pronouns for
all you moglodytes out there that are
confused about what pronouns are and why
pronouns are
important
[Laughter]
oh my God
um some people are saying uh Roger Stone
it could be Roger Stone it could be
Michael Flynn
here's here's what I want to tell you
though a map this number six person it
really doesn't matter who it is
it doesn't matter who it is right and
the reason why it doesn't matter who it
is is because how Jack and Jack Smith
has done this indictment
all right
if if he if he really wanted to say who
these co-conspirators were he would have
said it but he didn't say it out loud
right we know who they are based on the
information that he gave us in the
[__] indictment it's clear that one
is Rudy Giuliani wanting Cindy Powell
one's John Eastman a Jeffrey Clark uh
cheese girl there there there's obvious
ones and number six is kind of I don't
know I don't know I have no idea
it could be so many and the reason why I
think Jack Smith actually did this is so
that we are out here
postulating which one of these scumbags
is the one that's gonna probably be
indicted but what you have to remember
is this
here's what you have to remember about
this is this indictment is not over okay
we've seen it we've seen it with the the
documents case already
where they have the original indictment
where it has Trump
and won't matter what teen Walt team
cracker well not a
in the indictment
they did a superseding indictment roped
in another employee and added charges to
Donald Trump and Walt Mata okay
so it is likely that there will be
superseding indictments but
some are saying the reason why Jack
Smith is trying to keep this case
separate is to keep it pointed which
honestly worries me a bit
it does it worries me a bit because
normally when you have co-conspirators
in these conspiracy cases which Donald
Trump is charged with conspiracy
to obstruct an official proceeding and
he is also charged with the actual
obstruction of official proceeding you
see that you see how those are two
different things I'm not a [__]
lawyer you know this I I don't I'm not a
lawyer I didn't go to law school I just
have a little experience about federal
indictments
just a little
but here's the thing conspiracy is a b
is a [__] to beat
and the only reason why is because the
conspiracy you just have to prove that
people were trying to plan to do
something that's why Stuart Rhodes and
the proud boys are excuse me The Oath
Keepers and Enrique tario and the proud
boys were charged and convicted in a
court by by a jury are their peers of
conspiracy
to commit sedition
right
conspiracy because they actually to some
degree didn't commit sedition because
they didn't actually overturn the
government right
it was just conspiracy to do it
so again
he's charged with conspiracy
to commit to obstruct an official
proceeding
and he's also charged with the ACT
of obstructing official proceeding I
think that is very key
and that is where I'm kind of worried to
be quite honest when you charge someone
with conspiracy but you don't add the
co-conspirators now the reason why Jack
Smith would do this is because when you
rope in more people into an indictment
you prolong the process
because each defendant each
co-conspirator has the right to defend
themselves and to place motions in court
so when you add more people you add more
motions you add more time as it were
it's more time for discovery for each
individual prosecution of each
individual
foreign Jack Smith what he's doing
he's doing he's trying to prove me wrong
really honestly is what he's trying to
do not me directly but the idea that I
have
Donald Trump will not see the inside of
a courtroom or a jury before the
election I believe he's trying to manage
to do that I'm glitching again what the
hell is going on
anyways
as we work through the uh as we work
through the glitches here The Internet's
been crazy with me on this side anyways
anywho anywho
I believe what Jack Smith is trying to
do is to prove people what I'm saying
wrong they're trying to get him to court
as fast as possible
and the way that they would do that
the way that they would do that is to
have a measured pointed very strategic
indictment of Donald Trump
okay
now
adding the co-conspirators would muck up
that mess before the election it
definitely would I definitely do not
think that he is going to go on trial
for this document's case
no way in hell is he going to go on
trial for this documents case not with
judge Cannon and the primaries looming
I believe that there's going to be a
trial date set soon it will be punted
just like it was in the documents okay
see this is why I tell you so I tell you
don't get too excited about the news
that you're hearing because what is
today might not be tomorrow
what is today might not be tomorrow okay
just like in the documents case they set
a trial for what was it August I believe
they they then doj was like no we want
it in December
Trump's like I want it never in the
history ever I want to wait until I'm
dead to have this trial or some stupid
[__] I don't know what his argument was
ridiculous and judge Cannon's like well
we'll set it for May of 2024.
so what is today may not be tomorrow
right
and I think that's what Jack Smith is
doing when he's only indicting Donald
Trump on this indictment but I also
think it's a big risk because this is a
conspiracy case
generally speaking almost a hundred
percent of conspiracy cases in federal
court are tried with all the KOA
conspirators in one trial because it's a
conspiracy and you're trying to show
that these people acted together
in coordination to conspire for whatever
crime they committed right that makes
sense doesn't make sense to do it
separately that's why I'm kind of a
little worried about the strategy
but I trust in Jack Smith I trust he
knows what he's doing
I trust in the doj that they're going to
do their job which is to prosecute
crimes
that's why they should trust us to save
our democracy
now let's see
some people are trying to guess who
number six is and some people are trying
to guess who who's helping me co-host on
Friday Tom Fenton fitton fitton
uh he might yeah it could be could be
really honestly honestly to tell you the
honest truth I really don't give a [__]
who's number six right any of those
people that you're listing out that
you're like it could be this one it
could be that one it could be I'm good
with any of those people aren't you I
mean I couldn't get more excited than
any person on that list Steve Bannon
Roger Stone Mike Flynn Genie Thomas I
don't give a [__] who it is
when it when it's when we figure out who
it is and who's the co-conspirant and
who's probably going to get indicted for
helping Donald Trump overthrow our
government and overthrow our vote boy
I'm going to be hopping excited aren't
you I don't give a [__] who it is
oh boy just like just like you are going
to be excited
who the person is that's gonna help me
do bonehead of the week on Friday and
I'm gonna give it to you right now who
is the because you've waited long enough
I made you wait like 30 minutes
did you notice I do that sometimes I
just make sure that I hang on to
something
oh I gotta keep you I gotta keep you
watching right that's the point that's
the show that's why
uh Don says I tease I tease I tease I
tease see I'm still holding it from you
no I'll tell you who it is on Friday
we're gonna have Boston Brian with us
that's right we're gonna have Boston
Brian with us on Friday uh helping us do
bonehead of the week I'm excited to have
Boston Brian with us
um he's been trying to get on the show
we've been trying to get him on the show
and I finally thought you know what
that's a good idea everyone was kind of
requesting him in the chat uh to help us
with it
so he's gonna come help us with bonehead
of the week on Friday I think I'm still
glitching can you hear me can you
everyone's saying yay yay yay Boston
Brian you're excited about having Boston
Ryan I think Boston Ryan has been on
Hal's show several times everyone keeps
wanting me to go on Hal show or Hal to
come here someone said the other day
that we would break the internet I don't
know that we'd break the internet
I I know how talk to hell hell knows me
it's the the problem is a lot of times
we have the show at the same time which
isn't a problem necessarily we love
having the sparklers here on the Tony
Michaels podcast and I I know I know the
[__] fam loves to go over to Hal's
show
and get down with the sparklers I
understand this I know this
it just so happens that me and Hal do
our show at the exact same time just
happens to be but let me tell you
something I know how does different
shows at different times so maybe maybe
just maybe one of these days I'll
I will love go over there and and and
visit Hal on his show or have him on our
show
so and again I'm happy to have all the
sparklers here as I know Hal is glad
when the [__] fam goes over to his
show yeah see some somebody saying Hal
is on right now
and see you would say like Tony why
would you say that
I mean I'm not competing with Al
I mean maybe in the time slot or
something
but me and Al have talked about this and
I'm telling you we're both stubborn you
know this I'm stubborn he's stubborn he
ain't gonna move his time and I'm not
gonna move mine so we're just gonna have
to
share time that's just it that's just
all we're gonna do
but yes Boston Brian will join us Boston
Brian will join us on Friday for
bonehead of the week so you're not going
to want to miss Friday as Boston Brian
helps co-host on Friday for bonehead
bone head up
we're gonna get down and with bonehead
of the week uh as Gabe Sanchez is out on
vacation
out taking some reprieve everyone
deserves to repeat
at any given time just like I deserve a
pre right now we're gonna go to a break
when we come back I'm gonna take a quick
drink I don't know why this internet
keeps glitching I have no idea I hope
you can still hear me my video keeps
freezing up for whatever [__] reason
yeah it's been raining here which we
need the rain but I think it's affecting
then I think it's the infecting then the
intro wibs or something don't go
anywhere
we'll be right back right after this
we'll be right back Mark
is the Tony Michaels podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show it sounds like
the grand jury in DC is gonna give us
indictments on the trumpko conspirators
we're gonna find out who number six
truly is
Johnny please go conspirator number six
Genie Thomas come on down I'm just
kidding I don't really know
do you guys like my uh my um Talk Show
Voice or or what a game show Voice
come on down
sorry
I'm feeling silly today
I'm gonna show you a clip that you're
gonna [__] hate I know it's gonna
happen
uh just to give you a little bit of news
Harry Littman as you know a friend to
the show here I've interviewed Harry I
think a couple times during the January
6 select hearings he's on MSNBC uh
frequently Harry lippman has done some
uh legal analysis uh for Midas Touch and
he also has his own uh podcast as well
talking Fizz but Harry Littman uh has
said that it looks like the grand jury
is rolling out separate indictments of
Trump's co-conspirators now it's going
to be a separate indictment it's going
to be a separate case which means it'll
be a separate trial more than likely
it'll be on a trial after Trump's and
the reason why is because if they wrap
all those people up on that indictment
as co-conspirators and what will happen
is each person will have the opportunity
to prolong that process which means
which means the pro process will be
prolonged well past the election of 2024
for Reed Giuliani Sidney Powell
cheeseburger Clark a Eastman and whoever
Coke and spirit or number six is
and then any coaching co-conspirators
that are added to a a superseding
indictment
that's important too they can add people
right
and the reason why they would do that is
because they're trying to get their
cooperation now and maybe they don't
cooperate the way they want
or to the level that they want or don't
give the goods it is very very very very
very telling though that there is one
person that does not appear to be
someone who is going to be indicted
in this case in DC and his name is Mark
Meadows it is very like whoa that's a
loud [__] sound that he's not going
to be in now it's not it doesn't mean he
won't be but at this point it doesn't
look like Mark Meadows is on the
chopping block for indictments at this
moment again we are in this moment of
time not in that moment of time right
so
but it is very telling that Mark Meadows
is not part of these original
indictments are part of these original
co-conspirators
the reason why that's significant is
because Mark Meadows was standing next
Donald Trump almost the entire time he
was trying to overthrow the election
trying to overthrow your vote trying to
steal our democracy away trying to
become the Cheeto dust kangaroo King
of the United States by committing a
coup
he was there the entire time
so
the significant thing about it is Mark
Meadows probably has all the receipts
that he needs to absolutely bury Trump
maybe we'll see again
there are evidence in there is evidence
inside this indictment that we haven't
even seen in the January 6 elect
earrings and if you're looking for some
of them one of the most significant ones
is when Jeffrey Clark was told by White
House counsel cipolloni hey dude if you
keep doing this
the American people are going to get
[__] violent if you try to overthrow
there if you try to steal the election
from them like you're saying the
Democrats are doing
they're gonna [__] take to the
streets and there's gonna be violence in
the cities
and he was like
that's what we kind of want
I don't remember the exact quote
and I don't have to remember the exact
well you can go look it up if you want
the point is is that they did not care
if they were stealing away this election
if there would be violence in the
streets over them stealing the election
they didn't give a [__]
that is why it's all projection but I
want to show you a clip and I know this
is going to piss some of you off I
understand it I get it
I'm going to show you a clip of Rush
Limbaugh
I know he's dead ding dong the [__] is
dead
Rush Limbaugh
but Benny Johnson posted this um
this this morning
um and again many Benji Johnson she's
just a [__] idiot
Benji here says man I miss rush now more
than ever
now you can see Rush is a skinny and
feeble here
he was cancer ridden oh God bless his
soul my thoughts and prayers are with
Rush Limbaugh and all the dirt on top of
his grave [__] him
his death didn't come soon enough is the
way I look at it yeah I'm dancing on his
grave I don't give a [__]
[__] him
he had a massive Talent he used it for
all evil and delivered us fascism in
this country so [__] Rush Limbaugh okay
and if you don't like it hate me
whatever you want to do
but in this clip rush them ball he gets
almost everything right
almost everything right and it and it's
almost it's almost a description of his
entire [__] career
wrapped up and just just a matter of a
minute or two
of what his entire [__] career was
about
the entire thing
what the entire stick was what he was
trying to do to our democracy what they
were trying to do to the public well how
they were trying to brainwash and delude
normal average working Americans into
believing that democracy is bad
that we must have authoritarianism that
we need fascism in this country to rid
ourselves of whatever evils they think
they made up in their minds and their
delusional degenerate [__] little
Minds
but Benny Johnson thinks that oh this is
a great Clipper Rush
here is my response before I show you
this clip I said Rush was right in this
clip
the fascist cult was always just looking
for a desperate leader
since before Reagan
Benji here doesn't have enough brain
cells to realize this isn't the flex he
thinks it is
so I'm going to show you I know I'm
going to show you this clip of Rush
and I know I don't show clips of him a
lot and I know it's gonna piss you off
that I say he's correct here but when he
says this
he's just telling the [__] truth it
ain't the truth you want to hear it
ain't a truth that is a great Flex it
really isn't but listen I know they
desperately want Trump gone and I I know
that they desperately wanted codified
that Trump cannot run again because make
no mistake they remain scared to death
of you and they remain scared to death
of Trump trump 75 million 80 million
votes
again he he sprinkled some lies in there
I'm not saying everything he's saying in
this clip is right
but when he says when he says that we're
trying to desperately get rid of them
and desperately get rid of trump it's
not desperation it's knowledge to know
what fascism does to a country
it's all we're trying to do is protect
our democracy not and rid ourselves of a
bunch of fascist bastards in our
government that's all we're trying to do
okay we're just trying to fend off the
Nazis rush like you but let's go on
and I'm going to tell you you're not
going anywhere
even if Trump does you're not
they can't separate you from Trump
okay
so
I've been telling you for months months
months
why Donald Trump is going to be their
[__] nominee
I'm telling you this I've been trying to
give you evidence
and I'm giving you straight from the
[__] the fascist horse's mouth Rush
Limbaugh
he did this for 30 years he set them up
to do this
to defend and to to
worship Trump even if he's gone he says
they cannot get rid of you
and your bond with him listen it's
[__] weird and it's culty but it's
true
and more importantly
they can't separate you from the ideas
they can't separate you from Maga they
can't separate you from make America
great again
which I think remains one of our big
campaign strengths going forward they
believe that they can they can destroy
this bond that exists between you and
Trump if they somehow make Trump look
bad make Trump look like a reprobate
embarrass you about Trump they can't do
it because you came before Trump
did you hear that you came before Trump
do you know why do you know why Rush
knows that
because Rush did that
Russian knows Rush knows all this [__]
came before Trump
Rush knows this [__] come on
and you're wondering how I know
that Trump's going to be there and that
these people are not going to back away
from him
folks some people call me the rush limb
all the lift
that's why I don't play clips of him
normally
because he's dead too [__] him he's dead
why do I need to show clips of Rush
Limbaugh when he's dead but this one is
entirely relevant today
and tomorrow and the next day and all
the way up to the lead up to November
election
it is a cult
they are going to follow him in the pits
of hell no matter what because his
ideals his fascist ideas are the thing
that Bond
white Christian Nationalist and Trump at
the hip
100 percent full stop it is a cult
and you're not going to stop them from
worshiping their cult leader and that is
exactly what Rush Limbaugh is saying
right here
now is it [__] vile and saddening yes
it's gross what Rush Limbaugh did to
this country
I think that's why some people call me
the wrestling ball the left
maybe because I use my voice the way he
did in the opposite direction
I don't know maybe it's because where
I'm from wrestling Ball's from rural
Missouri I'm from rural Missouri
ball Rush Limbaugh had some legal
trouble I've had some legal trouble in
my past rush Limbaugh is is a College
Dropout I'm a two-time College Dropout I
got you on that Rush
maybe that's what pins us together I
don't know
I have no idea
maybe it's the fact maybe it's the fact
that I can use my talents to set a
narrative
and to set the country in a Direction
he set us in the wrong direction maybe
just maybe maybe
it's possible but I could set it in the
right direction
but Rush Limbaugh in this clip is
telling you something that you need to
know
it is not about Trump
did not do this
Trump did not create this he took
advantage he's an opportunist
they have been begging
looking searching for a desperate cult
leader for decades long before Reagan
even some people go back to Reagan
because they love oh they love they love
Reagan they love pretend that they like
Reagan right
but it was long before that that they
looked and searched for their desk their
desperate cult leader
and they finally found him oh my god did
they find him
and the king of grift
which is which is a very very very very
very
important foundational tool that a cult
leader has to have
but long before Trump
there was trumpism
long before Trump there was American
fascism long before Trump there was
right white Christian nationalism
long before Trump there were neo-nazis
in this country
and long after him there will be two
and that is why I'm telling you it does
it even listen the weirdest [__]
thing about Trump
here it has not happened yet
the weirdest thing that we're ever going
to see about Trump is 20 years from now
people are still going to be talking
about him and worshiping him they will I
know you're like come on man 20 years
from now that guy will be long gone in
history no he will not
he will be their martyr he will be their
King
neo-nazis all around the country will be
flying Trump flags for decades to come
it'll be wild [__]
there'll be churches that'll still be
praying for him to come save them in
some crazy ass [__] doubt me
doubt at your own [__] peril
and the reason why I show you this Rush
Limbaugh clip is because he's absolutely
correct
he's right
he's right it was here long before Trump
you think these these vile human beings
these Maga supporters these people who
go to these rallies and say crazy ass
[__] into a microphone you think they
just all of a sudden popped up
you think they're hatred just all of a
sudden manifest in them no
no
it was always there it always has been
and it will be
that is why you cannot let down your
guard
that is why you have to do the work of
democracy
it is vitally important
of exactly what rush them bought the
work that he did to destroy our country
and to Slow Roll us into fascism
it's very important
that's why I show you that clip I don't
know what do you think do you think I'm
the rush limb all to laugh now that
you've seen that clip a lot of people
have never even listened to Rush
Limbaugh I'm sure this is the first time
some of the audience members has even
heard his voice
or even watched him do his show
so what do you think do you think I'm
the wrestling ball the left now that
you've seen that I don't know
I don't know I don't know you wanna you
wanna see a a a little scumbag that
drives around in his car he's been
brainwashed by Rush Limbaugh for years
let me let me show you let me show you
what Rush Limbaugh was talking about now
again Russian Ball's been dead for years
and that clip was from years ago
okay
here is here's one of wrestling Ball's
biggest fans I'm sure I'm sure if you
asked this guy who's one of his main
Idols he'll say Rush Limbaugh listen to
this
[Music]
another indictment keep them coming Jack
Smith keep them coming
you know I'm not even mad about this
anymore other than that I think it's
funny I think it's hilarious I think
it's a joke I think anybody who thinks
this is legitimate is a joke
this man is gonna beat these guys down
we might as well put him back in office
tomorrow I mean I wish we could but the
way that these guys are going we're
gonna get this man elected
keep them coming Jack Smith
you see you see what I'm talking about
you see what I'm saying
you see what I'm saying when I say
Russian ball is right about what he was
saying because Rush Limbaugh knew what
he was doing he knew what he was doing
he knew he was lying to the American
people he knew he was pumping their
brains for a bunch of [__] every
single day over and over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over again he knew how to entertain
the people in a way that got them coming
back for more every single day for three
hours and continue them listening to the
brainwashed [__] all the [__] all
the lies
he knew that
he knew it what do you think he was
talking about in that clip he was
talking about all the work he'd done for
years on the radio
for years he'd done this [__]
now the problem is is that Rush Limbaugh
doesn't exist anymore
in the mainstream on on AM radio or FM
talk radio it exists on the internet
in a much more vile forms like this guy
Nick Fuentes
here you go here's Nick Fuentes an
outright Nazi okay this is this is the
modern day
Rush Limbaugh listen this
is supposed to be mad at Hitler I'm
supposed to be crossed with Hitler I
want this guy dead if I was in a room
with Hitler and that guy
me and Hitler would team up and [__]
that guy up we would kill that guy
Hitler would hold them down and I would
beat him to death
oh boy uh
listen this is Nazi grooming
and Nick Fuentes is getting tons of
young men in this country to listen to
him and destroying the minds
of young men in this country and
grooming them to be Nazis
folks I don't show you this for you to
go oh well
that that doesn't seem important it is
absolutely important
this guy's gonna team up with Hitler to
kill black people in his neighborhood
yes that's what he said Nick Fuentes
made up a story about a black person
littering in his neighborhood
and went on a tirade on his show about
how he would team up with Hitler to kill
the black person who littered
that's right
it ain't a death penalty because of
littering that's not what he believes
that he believes the death penalty
because the person is black
folks
that's what that's what we're up against
that's what we're up against
and we've got to know the threat
you think nip Fuentes is gonna stop
yelling and screaming when Trump's dead
you think Nick Fuentes is gonna stop
saying his nazi-ass [__] when Trump's
dead you are out of your [__] mind
you are out of your [__] mind if you
think Nick Fuentes is gonna be like you
know what Trump's dead I'm gonna stop
doing the Nazi stuff I'm gonna stop
doing that
you are out of your mind if you think
Benny Johnson and Ben Shapiro and Matt
Walsh and Michael Knowles and Ted Cruz
and Marjorie Taylor green and Matt gatz
Glenn Beck
all these pieces of sludge on Fox News
and Newsmax and oan are gonna stop
yelling and screaming fascist ass [__]
into microphones because Trump's dead
you're out of your mind
they're not gonna stop this stuff
they're not gonna quit it's the only way
they survive is to lie and to convince
millions of people to believe their lies
that is the only way that they survive
and the only way we beat back on them is
to be louder
to tell the truth the real [__] truth
rather you like it or not
I don't care how much you like the truth
I don't care if you're like well but a
poll says no one gives a [__] what polls
say they don't go ask go you may care
you may care if you watch the mainstream
media give you a poll to tell you what
you want to hear okay you may give a
[__] but go ask your friends who don't
watch the politics they don't pay
attention to it go ask them you got
friends I'm sure that have opinions that
don't pay attention to politics like you
do go ask them if they believe polls are
real and every single one of them will
tell you no
they'll say no
they don't believe that [__]
so why should you
why should you base your entire
political opinion the power of your
ballot on some poll that may not be real
that makes you feel good inside all warm
and fuzzy oh baby I hear Let Me Show You
an example one here you go here's an
example one
this is on Fox news right here's an
example and make you feel all warm and
fuzzy inside or to make you feel Doom
and Gloom
this is designed on Fox News folks this
poll is designed to show Fox News
viewers and to get them all warm and
fuzzy inside
this is propaganda 101. this poll is
probably not even [__] close to being
real even though the New York Times and
Siena College poll is doing it because
polls are outdated and Antiquated do you
think do you think gen Z answers their
[__] phone
have you ever met someone from gen Z
have you ever tried to call someone have
you ever tried to make a phone call
to someone who's gen Z
have you
ever
just try to call them they're not gonna
answer your [__] phone call
even if they know who you are you gotta
text them first
and say Hey you if you're gonna talk to
gen Z on the phone you gotta text him
first and then say and then say hey can
I call you it's probably gonna take you
two days of texting to get those
[__] on the phone
that's just their generation and
honestly it's rubbing off on most
Americans you're like wait a second I
don't actually have to take a phone call
are you telling me that I can tell
someone to [__] off just text me oh this
is great I love this gen Z has delivered
this for us so if you think all clothes
are correct
and all Po and people believe polls
that's the thing I'm trying to tell you
even if the polls are right
even if they are correct and I got
someone waiting in the wings that'll
tell you all kinds of [__] that you need
to know about polls
but I'm telling you
polls are only good enough to make you
feel good inside that's it and this is
what this poll on Fox news shows 71
percent stand behind Trump they're
trying to tell Their audience on Fox
News look everyone loves him
but 22 don't that's horrible for him if
you really look at this poll that's a
horrible number 22 percent of
Republicans are like [__] this guy
that's really bad that's horrible right
now for Trump
in a general election it doesn't matter
in the in the in the primary look what
he's doing 71 he's been indicted on 78
felony counts
four of them to try to overthrow our
government
and he's like yeah let me be in charge
of the government again
what the [__] and 71 of people like yeah
[__] yeah it makes me want to be with
him it's a cult folks it's a cult the
clip I just showed you of Rush Limbaugh
years ago telling you that trumpism
isn't about Trump
it isn't about Trump trump just is an
opportunist and he saw the opportunity
to be the desperate cult leader that
they always longed for
that fascism in this country needed
permission to be the worst version of
themselves
and that's what it is and that's why
he's indicted because he's a buffoon and
he truly doesn't understand what he is
and who he is and why he is in this
moment he truly doesn't because he's a
[__] idiot
just like he's an idiot when he's like
presidential records act and he's like
First Amendment which are not good legal
arguments
oh boy
I told you I didn't have a special guest
today and I'm so excited to have her
back so let's do this let's go to a
break let's go to the break and we will
have
the best political strategist my
favorite political strategist in the
entire world I believe she's the
smartest one and the reason why is
because she likes to use the upward a
lot they said listen they I know you're
not supposed to believe polls but there
are polls out there that will show you
that people who use the f word are way
smarter than people who don't so when we
come back I'm sure I'm sure our
intelligence will allow us to use the f
word a time or two as we're talking back
and forth don't go anywhere we'll be
right back with Dr Rachel bidikoffer
stick around docs next
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're back to the Tony Michaels
podcast
welcome back to the show
I was swimming in marketeers last night
I mean absolutely drowning in them
everywhere every time I posted something
they were in there like oh
[Music]
you're vile
you shouldn't say stuff like that that
that's pathetic you know it's pathetic
supporting a two-time impeached and now
78 felonies indicted president of the
United States former president United
States and what seems to be future
candidate of the Republican Party Dr
Rachel bittickoffer please tell me
please tell me why
these ignorant slugs are still going to
support this fool tell me Dr Rachel with
a golfer tell me why they're going to
it's great to see you my friend
oh that was great I mean you know
Republicans have a tried and true
technique to stay on the Trump train and
that is to avoid any real information
right so I was thinking about this last
night you know as you know I've been
I've been researching World War II the
rise of the third right other things
right
and one of the things that people relied
on a lot back then were pamphlet drops
right so like if the Nazis control the
information in Berlin how do you tell
people what's really happening with the
war you gotta jump a piece of paper
pieces of paper out of the airplane over
the city so that people can find it and
see the truth right like what we need is
a 21st century version of pamphlet drop
and I I that's how far my pondering has
gotten it hasn't come to like exactly
how that could be executed yet but
that's what I'll be noodling on but
that's really what we need right and and
here's the nice thing though this last
slate of charges they're rolling out the
defense last night and today and I'm
sure you're seeing this in your own you
know
um conversations that you're monitoring
which is terms that Trump's been
indicted about lying his lot he he can't
indict him because its first amendment
protected speech right and what I love
about this is that like they at least
now are telling the Maga base he's a
liar dude he lied and it shouldn't be a
crime to lie to you right so like I kind
of like this Frame I don't know that
it's going to work the way they
envisioned when they came up with it
because it's accepting and telling Mega
the one thing that they've refused to
accept and acknowledge themselves which
is that Trump [__] lied to them right
it was all a lie and I think that what
we might see some fracturing there I
think um I was watching Harry Littman
tweet about the docket today it looks
like some indictments are getting filed
from the grand jury for the
co-conspirators so I think that's a
really important step I've been a long
believer
that the more people who who supported
this criminal conspiracy at the state
level at the federal level who are
indicted the easier it will be to break
the Mad the Maga
um fever right because it takes it
Beyond just this one man and his one set
of crimes and and makes it more obvious
that the criminal conspiracy was was a
thing that happened right so I think
it's really important that Michigan's
taken the steps to indict their fake
electors that we're going to see this
action at afani Willis in Georgia really
soon I think that's going to be a
far-reaching indictment I don't think
it's going to focus only on Trump I
think it's going to trickle down to
quite a bit of the Republican Party in
the state of Georgia and I think that's
really what we need to do we need to
bring reality Earth one as much as
possible to the Maga world and and the
one way to do that is to hold the people
who supported cast of this Insurrection
and plot accountable
you know I I found it funny last night
because um there were people like
Charlie Kirk which you've met Charlie
Kirk in person so you know how feeble
and fragile that little white
nationalist is um but people like uh
Charlie Kirk and Tim Poole are like
there's gonna be a Civil War and I was
like Civil War where in our comments
section get the [__] out of here man
what are you talking about get the [__]
out of here I mean you got to look at
the facts and New York nothing happened
in Florida nothing happened when Jack
Smith indicted Donald Trump yesterday he
said hey [__] you got to be here
tomorrow I mean it is like no [__] two
days but he said you got to be here
tomorrow [__] to be arraigned he's not
wasting any time on this and I'm sure
Bonnie Willis is going to be the same
way and if you've been paying attention
down there in Georgia at the courthouse
not only is Bonnie Willis alerting the
authorities but she's alerting like the
county clerks up it's like hey this is
gonna be this could be some wild [__]
you may want to make sure you have some
precautions in place for your staff but
I think she's is just expecting the
worst just like Americans should expect
the worst out of these out of these
indictments we should not pin our hopes
that Jack Smith the Department of
Justice Bonnie Willis Tish James
Manhattan D.A is going to save our
democracy what we need to do is we need
to use the information like you're
saying that they're like yeah he's lying
you can't indict him for lying we need
to use that information politicize the
[__] out of it and get all the jurors
all 150 million of the jurors out there
to go vote that Donald Trump is [__]
guilty all the way down the ballot and
anyone who supports him because we truly
we truly are Donald Trump's jury in this
in this effort it is it is not it is not
just going to be penned upon a few
people in D.C Florida Georgia or
Manhattan or wherever the hell else he's
indicted it is us who is his jury and we
must use this information and politicize
the hell out of it to make sure that we
not only get people to turn out but to
engage engage in our democracy and I
think that that's the key Point here but
let me show you a clip
of co-conspirator number one Speaking of
the co-conspirators uh Grandpa farty
mcsharty Rudy Giuliani some people call
him Rudy kaluti I call him Grandpa farty
mcsharty because he he farted I like
better
I don't know all right grandpa farty
mccharty is true to my heart and the
reason why is because when he farted on
Jenna Ellis and he gave her covet I
think that moment in history is uh is
fantastic but here here is Rudy Giuliani
on Newsmax and it looks like he's gonna
cry I'm not gonna lie to you watch the
strange thing it does yeah
but the people bringing this and this
this count they have here conspiracy
against rights
they should be indicted for conspiracy
against rights for bringing this
indictment
knowing
nah so earlier on in this interview too
with Eric bollum he was he was making
the argument that you were saying about
the First Amendment which is wild and
crazy because in this indictment if you
actually go read it like if you just use
your brain and your eyeballs and you go
read it you'll know that Jack Smith has
taken the First Amendment off the table
and the reason why is because Jack Smith
did not indict him on anything Donald
Trump said at the ellipse to cause the
Insurrection there is no there is no
charge there about his his speech on the
ellipse to cause the Insurrection it's
all about the lead up and and the
afterwards of that speech that he gave
yeah we didn't charge him so that he he
immediately takes it off the table right
which is funny because Jack Smith knew
the argument that they were going to
make which was oh he's just telling lies
he was just saying stuff it wasn't real
because that's the argument that he's
been making this whole time and they
never changed their arguments they just
jumped back and forth from one to the
other but as we see this co-conspiracy
murder case play out I gotta ask you who
do you think because this is this is on
everybody's mind today everyone's
playing the [__] co-conspirator
number six Lottery who do you think is
co-conspirator number six Rachel
whitakoffer do you have a guess of who I
do I think I mean I don't know that I'm
right and I know people have this desire
it's going to be Jenny Thomas I I I
could it could be okay because she could
she does describe herself as a political
consultant but I think it's more likely
to be Jason Miller which for me that's
pretty good like he is uh Trump's you
know go-to campaign guy and uh have you
ever had any run-ins with Jason have you
ever had any run-ins with Jason at all
no you know I can't say that I've met
him like I have with Charlie Kirk I'd
like to meet him I'd like to meet him
and put him to the bit of Coffer you
know
I don't know that I could be within
spitting distance of some of these
people I don't know if I could help
myself but but here's the thing here's
the thing I was telling the audience
before because there's a whole list
there's Genie Thomas Roger Stone Steve
Bannon uh Mike Lynn I mean the list goes
on and on and on of these scumbags that
that this description and the indictment
possibly could describe right and I'm
like I don't care which one it is really
I mean any one of those people I'm gonna
jump up and down and be excited that
they're co-conspirator number six
because frankly their Coke is bigger
number eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen fourteen in my mind maybe not
in Jack Smith's indictment but they are
co-conspirators in the effort to
overturn the election in my mind but
tell tell the audience why it's so
important that politically not legally
because everyone wants to pin pin this
stuff on legal analysis tell them that
politically why it is so important that
these people are being co-conspirators
and being charged and how do we take
advantage of that in the election space
in the political space like what can we
do
right well I've for a long time argued
aside from the Myriad of other reasons
what we needed legal accountability for
the actions of these folks in trying to
you know seize permanent power because
it wasn't about overturning an election
or stopping or submitting fake electors
or whatever the [__] it was the point
was to seize permanent power in the
United States of America and American
democracy and where they have always
been benefited is in the act in that
absence of accountability there there is
a comms absence right so they're able to
spend their lives and downplay the
severity of Jan six and call it tours or
whatever all of the spin that they were
able to do has been one-sided why we've
sat in largely in silence waiting for
these investigations to play out so for
me when I would think about what the
work I was doing always was predicated
on you know this work for 2022 and
whatever is all important because we're
going to see accountability in the legal
system them I don't I don't think that
we could go into 2024 with as a refined
frame of democracy versus autocracy
which is what we're going to be
ultimately asking voters to choose uh
you know certainly if it's Trump
probably even if it's someone like dos
Santos uh as the nominee so like to be
able to to point to criminal activity
you know to these criminal indictments
into the legal activities are going to
come it really makes it harder for them
to exist on Earth too because it thrusts
the realities of Earth One into that
um you know into that orbit even when
they try to dance around it today last
night has been a really tough earth to
time period because the veil has fallen
the curtain behind the wizard right
hiding the wizard has fallen at least
temporarily to show them you know in
plain language this is what happened
this is how it happened and this is who
was involved in it right so I think
those things are really critical call
Legal accountability has always played
that double role of proving a number one
we're still a nation of laws and if you
do the crime you'll do the time and I
think that's important because I know if
I was a criminal defendant I'd be like
uh what about these guys like why am I
under investigation for tax fraud or
whatever the [__] it is when you can
overthrow the government and plain sight
so I think you know there's a lot of
functional reasons why we needed it but
the most important reason for my purpose
not the legal purpose but the political
purpose as you pointed out is is to be
able to force Earth One into Earth too
right well I I think I think it's
important too to look at this uh in the
lens that there is one person's name
that is absent from the indictments and
absent from the co-conspirators and it
shows just how important
um him being a coward truly is and
that's Mark Meadows Mark Meadows truly
is a coward at his core
um that's why he stood back and let
Donald Trump do this and that is why he
is now turning on Donald Trump because
he is a coward he has no principle he's
the most like Jim Jordan in there right
him and Jim Jordan are very similar
Political Animals in that regard right
and so when you think about you know
what the what the prosecution is laid
out is that they you know there was lies
that were constitutionally protected but
what happened was actions built on those
lies that were criminal conspiracies
right and to me it sounds like he's
going to have at least Mark Meadows
probably Mark Meadows and Jenna Ellis
testifying on the details and it's going
to be just damn I mean
well you know Jenna Ellis has not only
turned on uh Trump maybe uh criminally
or legally I should say in this case but
also politically she's really backing uh
Ron DeSantis which you know at her own
Peril Ron DeSantis is uh whoo boy um I
knew that he wouldn't last very long
because he's a weirdo but he's much
weirder than I ever imagined that he
would be but the point is this is that
some of his political allies have
already started to peel back from him uh
to find someone else to support because
they know they know at the end of the
road just like Bill Barr can't say I I
wouldn't vote for him like he won't say
it like he won't say I won't vote for
him and the reason why is because of
this Republican
this ideal that they have for years that
you have to vote based on affiliation
because no matter what the worst
Republican is not even close to the best
Democrat like you have to vote for that
worse Republican uh even if it's even if
they're horrible even if they get like I
don't know 500 felony counts against
them or or some [__] I wanna I wanna
point out some comments here
um this is a great question by Amy on on
YouTube she says what is the difference
between Stephen Miller and Jason Miller
one looks like a goebbles one looks like
a thumb but other than that there's
maybe not much difference between the
two I don't know I thought it was a
funny question maybe rhetorical uh also
I think someone just coined a phrase
from you on Twitch you've just been
bitter coffered
I like it I like it yeah
you know I I have one of the best
audiences in the world here
um you do that's why I every time you
ask me I'm like let me come hang out
with your fun fan fun fans because
they're great dude they are I have the
greatest audience in the world and they
always they always they love when I when
I even when I name drop Rachel
bittickoffer like I just I I just a hint
at it or anything they they love you
they love you so much and the reason why
is because they love your political
analysis and they love that you're so in
tune with what the country really not
only wants but needs to have to move the
Democracy forward in a place where we
don't have this this false narrative
that Trump is somehow popular popular
and trumpism is half the country because
that's all absolute [__] it's just
not true
um but what we've been doing a thing
called Roundtable of democracy but tell
people why this indictment why this
indictment is important but also why
it's it's so important to watch those
down ballot races because we got a lot
of places that we have to win not just
the presidency we have to we have to
make sure we keep the Senate we have to
make sure we advance in the house to
make a king Jeffries possibly the uh the
the next speaker of the house and
there's so many there's Governors races
out there uh there's State races out
there that we really have to we have to
get our act together in some of these
places so why is it so important how do
we make sure to make this top of the
ticket attitude
um trickle Downs into the ballot so that
people engage all the way through the
ballot how do we do that
wait wait we have to hit him where it
hurts right we have to do exactly what
Republicans have done to invigorate
their own Coalition into these down
ballot elections they've been rolling
this system out for over a decade now
and I talk a lot about it in the
upcoming book which you know Shameless
plug right but it talks about look what
Republicans did is nobody gives a [__]
about John Doe running for you know
Republican running for North Carolina
legislative seat they don't know who
their governor is they don't give a [__]
about state legislatures right so what
Republicans did is instead of like
wishing people cared or trying to like
pretend like maybe you know this or that
will interest them they just told people
through their advertising both Visual
and and the copy the writing
John Doe loves Donald Trump vote a vote
for John Doe is a vote for Donald Trump
right like or vice versa John Doe is the
is the only person that's going to take
it to Nancy Pelosi and Barack Obama the
dude is trying to run in the North
Carolina State Legislature okay he's not
[__] taking anything to Nancy Pelosi
and Barack Obama but what they have done
is they've set up a frame for the low
information low interest you know voters
and many of our side by the way leave we
are the big problem we leave like the
top Don president maybe governor and
then leave the rest of the ballot blink
right and that's because we're not tying
in this National frame into these um to
give people a reason to vote in them and
to make them Salient and and it does
require some
you know fifth grade level advertising
strategy if somebody if somebody doesn't
care about policy then making a policy
appeal to them you know vote for the
Democrat for the state house so you can
have clean water for your kids right
that's not gonna [__] do it dude you
gotta be like hey if you don't show up
and vote for Democrat Jane Doe in the
North Carolina assembly your daughter is
going to be you know chattel of the
state right I think you have to make it
worse right it's a lot more important
it's a lot more pointed message isn't it
and and you know because and then and
it's meeting the voter where they are
right not where we want them to be right
where voters actually are which is tuned
in tuned out and uninterested right
right so we have to we have to generate
the interest as they did in those down
ballot races so for me the answer Tony
in in a sentence in the book will lay
this out quite quite a bit is we have to
we have to adapt how Republicans run
down ballot races and and do exactly
what they've been doing for a decade
I couldn't agree with you more and I'm
so glad that you got to the Shameless
plug I totally did not try to bait you
into a Shameless plug there
um but everyone there is a book coming
out at the probably the most brilliant
book in the history of politics by Dr
Rachel bittickoffer her link tree is
down below but go follow Rachel
everywhere Rachel give us your Shameless
blood because I know the book isn't
available yet but it is available for
pre-order and so many audience have done
it but the people who don't know about
it give them your Shameless plug of this
book and where they can pre-order it
yeah for anybody who's ever wondered why
do why do we lose when they win when
there's such a shitty product this book
is for you okay it's going to teach you
you know hey how atypically wonderful
you are if you if you listen to Tony
Michael's pod you're particularly
wonderful but if you know the name Kevin
McCarthy you actually are an abnormally
informed individual and therefore you
know we've we've constructed our comms
and our political system on this
Assumption of voter engagement that's
unrealistic and
um doesn't match reality so the first
half of that book is going to teach you
what I know as a political scientist
that I picked up from my trading in
years of of work and research on voter
behavior and get you up to speed to why
it is something called negative
partisanship strategy which is something
Republicans have been using quite well
and we need to use we used in Michigan
and Arizona and other races in 22 and
held the red wave back but we're not
using it across the board in our
political election strategy and what we
want to be doing is we want to be
setting up a high stakes a motive frame
that's brand up for Democrats brand down
for republicans and you know attaches
the word extremist and radical as much
as we can to the Republican party they
are not going to tell voters what
they're all about they're not going to
tell them and we're going to have a
National Abortion ban right our job is
to tell voters what's coming what that
what what the modern Republican party
means for them and how it's going to
directly threaten them not other people
not brown people no offense not trans
people themselves personally because
that's how most of the human psychology
is is based on people care about what's
going to happen to them and their own in
tribes and we have to meet that
advertising home where it is
so where do we find this book because I
have some people here say they already
pre-ordered it where do they go to
pre-order the book yeah that's great
it's on Amazon there's a pre-order there
for both the hard copy the Kindle and
the audible book so I will be recording
the audible book version so
um if you want to hear me read out hit
him where it hurts then that's a good
option for you and uh you know we really
need these pre-order sales I take so
it's going to take a village with this
book folks this book is I dedicate it to
you it's written to you it's to Team
America to The Average Joe's and Jane's
out there working hard to save our
democracy from you know imminent
collapse and uh I need I need everybody
to help spread the word because if we
don't if we can't fix our messaging and
our election electioneering strategy and
fix the rest of the system in time for
these 20 24 Senate races then we stand
in real danger of losing the Senate so
the more people who hear about this book
hear about negative partisanship
strategy see how it worked in other
places in 2022 I think the better our
odds are for holding on to to both get
flipping the house back holding on to
the Senate and then you know most
crucially winning the presidency and
keeping fascist out of power
well everyone go to amazon.com just
search Rachel bittickoffer or bitikoffer
it's going to bring up hit him where it
hurts just go to amazon.com search beta
Coffer or Rachel bidikoffer or hit him
where it hurts you'll be able to
pre-order I you know what I can't wait I
can't wait to get a copy of this book
but I can't wait to hear you read it to
us that's gonna be the best part about
the whole thing I think I'm gonna get
both copies the hard copy and so you can
read it to me I might just read it while
you're reading it I think that's my what
I do I don't know I I love hanging that
sounds cool yeah it's my friend I have
to tell you I I ordered spare only I
would never read a book like that ever
but because it was Audible and read by
Prince Harry
obviously
okay and I wanted to hear like how to
Snoopy snooty upper crossed English
sound because like apparently in England
you can recognize the aristocrats just
by how their English accents are so I
wanted to hear that too but anyway yeah
that that made the book for me was
hearing Prince Harry um you know call
his daddy daddy
whatever he calls him
that's that's fantastic my friend I'm so
glad you came you know the audience
wants you to come by and do a round
table democracy I have several ideas of
topics that we could talk about and show
them tools that they could use we're
doing a great thing over on patreon that
we're making available to the public
where we teach people and give them the
tools to engage in their democracy and
I'd love for you to stop by and give
them a 15-minute Workshop
um and I know I've texted you about it
before but it would be great to hear
about how to pick out I one subject that
the audience wanted was how do we pick
out these most important races and I
know you know that and how to pick out
the most important races I know you
could break it down just a few minutes
that would be a great workshop for
everyone to to take to see Dr Rachel
bittickoff for the best political
strategist in the entire world my
favorite my favorite political
strategies in the entire world one of my
one of my favorite uh co-conspirators in
the f word
um as always Dr Rachel bittickoffer
we're glad to have you here thank you my
friend for coming by and giving us all
your wisdom reward everyone go down to
the link below it's the link tree follow
Rachel everywhere Twitter threads we
love you doc we love you have a great
day all right
all right Dr Rachel bidakoffer
how can you not love her right how can
you not love her what a great ending to
the show I'm glad you guys stuck around
to watch Dr Rachel bittickoffer as
always and I'm serious about having her
on Roundtable democracy I think that's
one thing that's one of the ones we
could do in the coming weeks
is how do we how do we know what races
are most important like how do we
determine that like what what gives us
the determination of what races are most
important at that particular moment
because I've gotten a lot of people in
this Roundtable democracy they've said
things like oh well I live in this state
so it won't matter
yeah it does matter you can engage even
if you live in a state where the
engagement in your state may not be so
important you can help other people
engage in other states there's nothing
stopping you from helping others engage
in other states in those key races and I
thought you know I know doc knows how to
pick out these races that is most
important and where your time is most
spent the other thing too
is you if you're gonna donate money you
want to know where to donate money to
and how to donate it I know Dr Rachel
bittickoffer could do a whole workshop
on that so I hope we can have her on the
round table of democracy and just to
remind you
just to remind you if you want to
participate in the round tables of
democracy go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels that's patreon.com D Tony
Michaels we're doing planning means over
there I think I'm going to do a round
table tomorrow uh so many people have
asked where do I find the how to
register voters the laws in my state I
want to show you that resource I just
want to Tick-Tock you through it just
show it to you show you what it's about
show you how to search through it and
then maybe we'll have someone on that
really an expert later on that'll really
do a deep dive real quick Deep dive on
how to do certain things on that
resource because it's not just enough to
tell you to engage in democracy I want
to give you the tools now to engage in
your democracy I think it's super
important and the work that we're doing
over on patreon with the patreon members
is super cool so if you want to
participate in the Roundtable democracy
go to patreon.com
but don't worry even if you're not a
patreon member we're still going to make
it available to you
to you
if you if you want to see these
roundtables of democracy just make sure
you subscribe on YouTube right here at
the Tony Michaels podcast make sure to
hit subscribe right now
and also liked the the video you know
what I mean that we're on but you can go
to the playlist tab if you go to the
playlist tab I've set up a playlist that
is called Round Table of democracy you
can go watch our work that we're doing
on patreon there absolutely free it does
not cost you a single dime to watch
these workshops once we put them
together once we develop them we will
make them free to the public for you to
look at and you to use those tools and
utilize that information to go engage in
your democracy the key here is to help
you find those tools and find the way
that you want to engage so many times
I've heard this time and time again I
don't know what to do I have no idea
what you mean when you say engage what
should I do what can I do everyone has
talents every last one of us and I'll
tell you this audience is some of the
most talented people in the country and
on the planet that's right we have we
have people all around the world that
watch us here at the Tony Michaels
podcast and you are some of the most
talented that we have I've tapped the
audience several times the moderators
were audience members it's the people
who helped tweet the people who helped
write descriptions the people who helped
do art that people who make videos that
are silly that we play on the show
they're all talented people but you have
a talent and you can use that talent to
engage in your democracy and over the
next year as we're doing these
roundtables of democracy you can find a
way that is best for you to engage and
the tools that you need are probably
available we just gotta find them and
provide them to you so that's what the
round table of democracy is about so if
you want to participate in a Roundtable
democracy again go to patreon.com the
Tony Michaels or just go to the
tonymichaels.com the link is there
to participate in the Roundtable of
democracy but if you want to watch the
videos free you can't afford patreon no
problem no big deal
we're gonna make those videos available
to the public go to the playlist tab on
the YouTube channel so subscribe now
you'll find the playlist for roundtables
of democracy and all the videos and all
the tools there also you can watch the
show live every single weekday on
Facebook too at the Tony Michaels you
can also catch us on Twitch so follow us
over there for free on Twitch
twitch.tv slash the Tony Michaels don't
forget if you have your Amazon Prime
account
link to your your Twitch account don't
forget to re-subscribe and if you want
to give the show some support
link your Amazon Prime account with your
Twitch account
and you can give us some support over
there by giving us your one free
subscription you get with your Amazon
Prime account
when you link it to your Twitch account
we get a couple bucks every month so do
that make sure to resubscribe also
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
POD at the Tony Michaels and I am Gabe
Sanchez and download every single
episode on Apple Spotify and Google it's
free99 over there I appreciate you guys
hanging with me today and hanging in for
Dr Rachel bidikoffer it's indictment
week tomorrow is arraignment day yeah
boom boom boom
arraignment day and you know we'll be
here same time same place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon